im august 1914 beginnen die europäischen
großmächte einen krieg der zum trauma
einer ganzen generation werden wird vier
jahre lang bekämpfen sich die nationen
mit allen mitteln 1918 hat deutschland
den krieg verloren die bilanz über 10
millionen tote und die zerstörung des
alten europa
in der separaten die siegermächte 1919
über die neue weltordnung und die
gründung neuer staaten in europa polen
war vor über 100 jahren von deutschland
österreich ungarn und russland
aufgeteilt worden jetzt soll der staat
auf die landkarte zurückkehren auf
kosten der verlierer des weltkriegs vor
allen dingen auf kosten deutschlands
deutschland polen sind komplementär
verhandelt das heißt es gibt seitdem
teilung polens gibt es die goldene regel
in der europäischen politik
wenn deutschland etwas gewinnt dann auf
kosten polens und wenn wie 1918 19 polen
etwas gewinnt dann auf kosten
deutschlands auch im westen muss
deutschland gebiete abtreten
doch besonders schwer wiegen die
verluste im osten
die deutschen müssen auf westpreußen
posen und teile schlesiens verzichten
ganze wird zur freien statt erklärt
ostpreußen vom rest des reiches
abgetrennt polen wird damit zu einer
neuen macht im osten zum missfallen der
allermeisten deutschen
der verlorene deutsche osten ist für die
parteien der weimarer republik
eines der ganz wenigen themen dass sie
wirklich verbindet sie sind ja zutiefst
verfeindet untereinander linke und
rechte später auch die
nationalsozialisten und kommunisten und
was diese parteien gemeinsam haben ist
die ablehnung oder die feindliche
einstellung gegenüber dem grenzverlauf
zu polen
die deutschen fühlen sich betrogen
hintergangen
die frage nach dem verlauf der neuen
deutsch polnischen grenze bleibt
umstritten und erregt die gemüter in
beiden ländern in deutschland formieren
sich paramilitärische verbände die frei
kurs sie rufen zum kampf gegen den neuen
politischen nachbarstadt auf und liefern
sich brutale gefechte mit polnischen
nationalisten umstrittener landstriche
[Musik]
als blutende grenze sind die zwischen
deutschland und polen umkämpften gebiete
unter deutschen revanchisten bald
bekannt
[Musik]
nach 1920 hören die kämpfe an der grenze
zwar auf doch viele deutsche warten nur
darauf eines tages gegen den verhassten
polnischen nachbarstadt loszuschlagen